[Music]
when I first started in the wig business
the hair alone could be up to 175
dollars an ounce let's just fake there
was more money in here than heroin
my stock of hair right now is probably
worth over a million dollars my name is
Nicolas Piazza and I'm a wig maker hair
stylist weight designer I started doing
wigs almost from the beginning of my
career this is my 50th year actually
these are some covers that I'd done for
some beauty magazine I used two pounds
of hair to create this style I worked
for the Kenneth's beauty salon which was
at that time world renowned all the
celebrities all the movie stars
including people like Jack well known
Asus and Marilyn Monroe we'll clients
there I opened my own salon on the Upper
East Side I was there from 1985 until
2010 and I moved into the salon I'm in
today as Gloria one so it takes about
five or six weeks to make a wig the job
of crocheting the hair is called
ventilate the ventilating needles come
in different sizes so if we're doing
very fine work they'll use a needle that
only takes one or two hairs in each knot
and if we're using a heavy wig we might
have a needle that takes up to ten years
in each knot sometimes the more delicate
wigs actually take longer than the very
thick ones at one time there was the
synthetic wig boom and everybody had a
synthetic wig and now people seem to be
much more interested in the quality and
they're willing to spend the money for
my customer exchange from 3850 up to
five thousand dollars you know and I've
made wigs
that I've had to charge more than that
for because I had to do them in a hurry
and paid through the nose to get it done
my clients are a variety of people it's
the kind of thing where you get a lot of
satisfaction when you have clients that
are undergoing medical treatments
sometimes it actually held them back
from getting their medical treatments if
they told that they were going to have
hair loss and then once they got the wig
and they saw that they look as good or
in many cases even better than they look
before they go into their treatments
with a lot better attitude I don't know
what sets me apart I care about what I
do and also I know I'm good at it and
when you good at something you enjoy
doing it
[Music]